hold on you're canadian and chose to go
to america and pay for college
you didn't pay what was your scholarship
in coffee
what'd she say
women play hockey
oh
you mean that on the grass like the
field hockey thing
that's called figure skating that's not
called hockey
hold on do women really play hockey
oh dude that's just unfair
wait what position were you
center
okay
is that like a cuter one
say what
your husband okay what's her name
[ __ ] is beautiful what's up all right
[Applause]
i don't know if you look around though
but you are surrounded by black people
bro
they got you of them all angles dude
get them get them
you said you're half black
half your family judges you man that's a
good that's a tricky one right there bro
being a minority and into magga
are there any minorities that could be
into maggot where it makes sense what do
y'all think
what about native americans
you don't think native americans want to
make america great again
you don't think they're listening to
donald trump like we need to stop
immigration like man we should have done
that [ __ ]
500 [ __ ] years ago before these white
[ __ ] got over here
put down the peace pipe build the wall
chief what you doing
black and white
knew that [ __ ] pops is black her mom is
black
pops is black mom wait that's what's up
hey you rarely see the other one
step it up sisters catch some white dick
every once in a while what the [ __ ] huh
we got good dick too
it's not as long but you know it stays
around
[Applause]
we got cubans out here
cuba is really my favorite yo i'm not
gonna lie
[Applause]
i love
i love okay
[Applause]
[Music]
i love cubans because uh
y'all turn into conservative republicans
immediately after getting to america
like
y'all are refugees
immigrants
and the second you get that dry foot
the second that foot drive
you're like okay any immigration he said
no he said no hey he said no immigration
hey it's too many people it's too many
people
how how hey we need a system we need law
we need law
where my food died
foot dry
i'm american now feel it feel it touch
it
touch it
okay i cannot play domino at the table
there's too many people coming
i cannot play domino
how do i play domino if everybody coming
i'm not like you i'm dry foot you went
back that's different that's different
that's different
that's different i'm dry
son cubans
cubans you good bro this guy about to
die
it's true right cubans wearing the maga
hat
cuban said son they just got here
cubans that just got here total make
america great again bro
back to win now we need to make it great
again
like when do you remember it great
hey i seen the movie i seen the movie i
seen the tv show i said i love lucy
it was great back then
what's up bro
[ __ ] aquaman in the front row
darkness
handsome [ __ ] look at him
dude serving tables and dick afterwards
i better watch
[Applause]
god bless you [ __ ] latinos man
uh puerto ricans and dominicans just
you're the same we don't care
uh
we don't care uh just on behalf of
everybody not latino you're saying i
know you think you're different you're
not [ __ ] different it's
we're so different no you're not a
different right
no they dance like this we don't like
this
[Applause]
only reason dominican girls dance like
this because they got stds brother cuz
he's burning
it's burning bro
[Applause]
that [ __ ] is oh i need to get checked i
need to get shake
[Applause]
[ __ ] bachata my bachota is on fire is
that your girlfriend right there
and then what's that guy right there
that's your best friend come on bro
come on bro
this forever single ass [ __ ] out
here come on
say what
you had her first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
crazy man
[Applause]
hold on you behind the music looking
[ __ ]
what the hell is happening over here so
wait a minute you guys are all friends
you guys hooked up first he was in
survival mode don't take that personally
like because i was about to go in
[Music]
and he was like i gotta stop
this girlfriend
[Applause]
[Music]
ready to go the second he found out he
was in front of he was third wheel he
was like now i'm telling everybody this
community's gonna know
all right
everybody
are you born and raised here in hawaii
no no it's okay
it's okay i'm not going to tease her
she's too sweet man
she's too sweet
you're not
you're born raised mainland how long
have you been here
that's the same question sweetheart
you around all these asians you still
can't do math how the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] doesn't rub off a little bit
or nothing
how long have you been here what's your
name first of all can i guess oh mary
that's what i thought
white women only had three names up
until like 10 years ago
it was like mary nancy gertrude that's
it
now white women get weird names like
toast
so mary so mary okay how long have you
lived on the island
oh you're just visiting
oh okay i was just trying to figure that
out
why'd you come to the island
oh that'd be sweet if that was the case
but i don't think so
bro this table is wild man has it
this [ __ ] looks like a porno i do not
want to watch this
did they really did they get rid of it
miss
they didn't get rid of it yet
what'd you say
you never had an abortion that's good to
know i didn't ask that but
i didn't ask that at all who's that next
to you who's that's your son okay
well i knew that there was a little
tension when she said that
she's like i never had an abortion
i kept all my kids
now i'm taking the comedy shows on a
[ __ ] sunday
when i could be at home watching matlock
reruns what the [ __ ] is this about
you don't always have to get the
abortion this you know
you could go the other way swallow them
[Applause]
you shouldn't even know what i'm talking
about
[Applause]
she said i have three kids i do know oh
my goodness bro
i don't know why i'm rubbing my belly
where are the other two you don't want
to bring them out
you don't take them in public
is there a reason for that
huh
one's 15 and then the other one you know
how old they are now you forgot okay
one of them fifteen the other one we
lost that [ __ ] a long time ago
might as well aborted him i left that
[ __ ] at walmart
oh man thanks for coming out with your
mom bro
what's your name
you paid for it yeah he brought you that
was your date bro
now i didn't want to say it
but up north they got some rumors about
alabama
[Applause]
he says i'm from mississippi bro
we just [ __ ] cousins
[Laughter]
[Music]
i ask you a question at the end you have
one eye
i thought that [ __ ]
for the last 45 minutes
for the last 45 straight minutes i've
been looking over every once in a while
like dude this guy blinks with one eye a
lot bro what
it's like is there no way
what happened
you got a shot out with a roman candle
were you holding it
dude this is crazy so another kid is
holding a roman candle he lights it and
you're like whoa the top of that looks
cool
yeah yeah
he's really set in the mood for this
[ __ ] huh
you telling this story like a girlfriend
you don't do patch bro you don't go
patch ever
he said he used to do a patch but he's
too sw who was laughing at somalian look
they think that's a pirate
we will show you pirates
the patch gets too sweaty
you go
wait a minute you got you got kicked out
of the navy
they don't like that [ __ ]
oh dude yeah but you could be the guy in
the submarine right because you only
need one
well
you come in with one either like boy do
we have the job for you johnson
god damn handsome ass indian look at you
are you indian or pakistani indian yeah
relax there's [ __ ]
two billion of you you don't have to get
that
hindu muslim sick what are you
no [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm saying what's the background why
y'all take so long for this [ __ ]
from bombay
and what you're just naming more [ __ ]
that you know doesn't
what's their religious background
they're not religious either what about
their parents
you don't know them
you know you know i know you're lying
right you know
you know i know you're lying right now
none of us ever met a non-religious
indian parent in our life
none of us ever met anomaly indian
parent indian parent non-religious
that's what he got to say because his
girl ain't indian that's why
they weren't feeling that [ __ ] were they
what's your back you're asian right miss
what type of asian
your taiwanese that's a good one
nah that's a good one that's like china
2.0
right
because
taiwanese
right i'm getting that right
taiwanese were like [ __ ] we out
and then they were like japan's too far
let's just stop right here this island
nah this island is good we're not going
all the way
you're like those indians that made it
to like trinidad
you know the indians like we're going to
america and then the first island
they're like [ __ ] pull over
this is far enough
i'm ready
they were so close bro
now they out there in the caribbean
thunder clapping
they went from
[Applause]
what about you other indian i don't even
know if you're indian i assume you're
indian
all right what type of indian i am
punjabi are you sick
you're sick that's what's happening
[ __ ] with six man
those are the dudes that wear the turban
and [ __ ]
and they got that bracelet that little
silver bracelet
that's a badass bracelet
no for real because back in the day that
used to be a sheath
that would protect them from swords
because the six were the warrior class
of people in india
and then over the years you know the
meaning has changed now it's used to
rest on the steering wheel of an uber
but
son
if they got that bracelet locked on that
steering wheel though
they ain't never crashing dude never
crash it
you let vishnu take the wheel dog
welcome back you guys trading off p's
tag team and appease i like that that's
a good move
did you wash your hands
you do
oh okay man we don't do that
we only wash our hands if someone else
is in the bathroom
yo and we might not even do that we
might just turn on the water and look
back like is he looking or
is he watching me fake wash my hands
sometimes you even want to tell the dude
like yo you don't gotta wash them i'm
not judging you bro just go
be great don't be great i know you
didn't pee on your hand
man we do not wash our hands if i wipe
and nothing comes on the toilet paper
i'm not washing my hands either i'm not
i'm not gonna do it for what reason for
what reason
my [ __ ] is magical and my [ __ ] told me i
don't need a wash
okay
you have to because you're all invested
in you you know
what's that i don't have to
i could just whack and then it's done
i touched my dick but my dick is clean
how often does a guy wash his dick
before you suck it
[ __ ]
you make him wet wipe his dick before
you suck it
no you just whip that thing out you suck
it
like i don't get women are so weird like
you're cleanliness [ __ ] right it's like
like i'll use a [ __ ] wet wipe for
your hands or use it what is that lotion
called not the lotion it's clear
purell right it's it's you purell with
everything but then when we finger you
never purell
right my hands still smell like
hamburgers and you don't even care
i'm smelling my hands as hamburgers bro
i'm just saying you require more cleanup
because you don't have a stream you just
have like a
release your [ __ ] is
have you seen women pee that [ __ ] is a
mess
you pee in one stream don't lie to me
don't [ __ ] lie to me try to pee one
stream that's just coming down both of
your legs
yes that's why you gotta squat way back
like that
you ever see a girl piss in the [ __ ]
street
never once you've seen a girl just piss
like that in the street
right
if you had any control of the stream you
just lean over you pee like that
but every time they pee they're like
behind a car
in this like weird squatted motion
right
just screaming at their foot block me
block me
block me
right and you're just [ __ ] peeing
into your boot that's what you're doing
you're pissing right into your [ __ ]
boot
no toilet paper nothing
there's a boot full of piss
that's why you wear open-toed shoes so
it just slides right through
women time to fight for equality
brilliantly
right i mean brilliant
5 000 years
man we were fighting lions and tigers
and hunting buffalo
and women
we'll just pick the berries you guys got
that that's
you guys all right
you guys are brave look at
wow so courageous look at you hunting
that buffalo
second they put air conditioning in
office buildings women are like we want
equality
march for it girls
what's in illinois though what is it
oh the rippers
is there alcohol you got a great voice
i mean you're gonna die from cancer soon
but until then you got a great voice
you're heard his voice bro that [ __ ] was
like half stephen hawking half
rooney armstrong that [ __ ] was amazing
you hear that voice right there
they call you what
are they being sweet
they should call you lung cancer loop
as i'm smoking a cigarette
you take this cigarette give that back
to you
i don't need that future
you guys have been a fun show man
that's the thing about those moments
they could never happen again what a
cool thing to be part of right
and i'm saying that because he'll be
dead
[Music]
how old are you guys
just turned 18 essay let me
everybody stop let me help you
let me help you answer that [ __ ]
question again okay
do not ever say just turned 18
again in your life
this guy's trying to get locked up over
here right
if she's 18 you go 18 18
and legal don't be like just turn you're
not the
[ __ ] brazzers title that you just
gave me for her
jesus christ jailbait
you look like one direction and you're
about to go directly to jail that's just
he was proud of that [ __ ] too wasn't he
steve
he's like just turned 18 yesterday
fresh as they come
[Applause]
that's like a hamburger from the
creamery man let me tell you
so what was it like [ __ ] when she was
17.
[Applause]
how many kids you have miss
just one kid
after that you're like no more
it was wild having it yeah
did it come out of a different hole than
you thought
it came out of your vagina though
and and you had uh with the pain meds or
oh no you went natural
all natural
you got a loose [ __ ]
i need to meet your magnum wearing
husband ellie
opening you up you're all [ __ ]
just walking to the hospital like got
him
cat stock
[Laughter]
one push the whole baby came out
that's nuts
is that your daughter right there oh my
lord
little spoiled brat never had to
struggle for [ __ ]
the rest of us were stuck in a [ __ ] for
24 hours
getting our heads smashed in the whole
[ __ ] time
bro that's how you know asian [ __ ]
are the tightest bro
cause they got the most you know
that's why white people got round eyes
and big old [ __ ] we'd be walking out
of like all right i'm out of here mom
now we're in west palm beach or palm
beach
west palm beach
and uh you said
pressure what'd you say
you're not sure
thank you for saying that out loud i
really
feel like that got us somewhere
that's what most people would do right
hey is it raining outside
i don't know
i just want you to know
it was you
oh that's what's up
thank you what is the difference sir
you have no idea you're a big [ __ ]
latino man
holy [ __ ]
dude did they just hop on you as the
boat
welcome to the show bro you want
mcdonald's if this ain't the blackest
[ __ ]
yo this [ __ ] showed up late
and brought chicken if that ain't the
blackest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
this is your boyfriend miss is your
boyfriend
what
it's just your friend how you feel about
that description
you don't think he put on his best
soccer jersey to be friends is that
[ __ ] ironed his best soccer
jersey oh
he's like she would give ronaldo some
[ __ ] let me put this [ __ ] on
i'm rooting for you bro
i'm team you dog even though you showed
up late you know what man you want to be
honest with you right now
i hope her period comes just as late as
you did
he will be right on time with that
pregnancy test i promise you no
mcdonald's stop nothing
this is a first date you took him here
he took you here
yo that's a keeper bro
isn't that not a keeper dude
a [ __ ] keeper and you came late this
is not mine dawg this is [ __ ] right
here love you dog and now what about you
you're asian
right are you math asian or fighting
asian
uh oh
[ __ ]
i'm not gonna lie math i mean i like
math asians i think a little better
but what is your background though
philip that's a fighting asian i'm i'ma
hate to break it too
that's a fighting ass i just found out
about filipinos recently
i had no clue dawg
i would see these filipino chicks i'd be
like damn
why these sexy ass mexican [ __ ] speak
chinese
you ever hear people say that about me
that the mexicans are stealing the jobs
you ever heard people say that
you never heard that
you never heard that
lying ass [ __ ] around
i'm not making that up though right i'm
not
first of all that's the stupidest thing
i ever heard in my life how the [ __ ] do
you steal
a job
i never seen a mexican walk into a
restaurant give me the dishes that [ __ ]
never happened in my [ __ ]
[Applause]
no no we don't want the money rubber
gloves
don't touch my lips
so stupid
if you're gonna steal a job
wouldn't you steal
a great job
[Music]
like who is deciding to steal these
[ __ ] jobs that's what i wanna
are you ready to steal some jobs today
yeah minimum wage we can do work
i wish they would steal a good i wish 40
mexicans would just raid the apple store
the genius bar is ours
the [ __ ] out of here nerds
it's mexicans to run the apple store or
not
just got nerds walking what are you
making something about silly max
if we can sell oranges we can sell
apples okay get the [ __ ] outta it
so i'm totally pro teachers [ __ ] kids
i'll tell you what look i'm very
i'm not okay with it i'm pro i'm
doubling down
i'm doubling down on it i'll tell you
why
i looked up these little psychos that
shoot up the schools you know these
little psychopaths right every single
one of them said they did it for the
same reason
not because of bullying by the way they
said they did it because they weren't
getting late
we got a question we need to ask
ourselves guys
are these teachers monsters are they
heroes
forget no child left behind suck a dick
save a school that's a slogan yes
yes
we got to keep our babies safe
we got any female teachers in the
audience tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
i hope you're willing to go the extra
mile
i'm not joking you see a weird kid
during lunch you know the weird kid the
kid whose jeans don't touch his sneakers
you see one of those hovering jeans kids
in the corner twisting a squirrel's head
off his shoulders
suck that kid's dick
empty balls make safe hauls